le groupe al dur pour nous mais madame
de sade
monsieur le commissaire nous disons tous
la même chose et c'est bien naturel
au fond si les terroristes ont frappé la
tunisie à deux reprises en trois mois au
musée du bardo et à sousse c'est parce
que la jeune démocratie tunisienne est
en train d'aller bien c'est parce que la
transition démocratique se déroule bien
et c'est ça que les terroristes essaye
de viser pour m afin et pour mettre à
mal donc évidemment ça implique que
notre union européenne soit présente aux
côtés des tunisiens et aux côtés de la
tunisie d'une façon plus importante
encore que ce que nous avons fait par le
passé
on doit être présent sur le plan de la
sécurité vous l'avez dit sur le plan de
la gestion par exemple et du contrôle
des frontières avec la libye ceci est
une évidence on doit être présent sur la
question du flux migratoires il faut que
nous gérions avec eux ces flux de
migration tunisiens et européens on doit
être présent évidemment au plan
économique
vous avez parlé de remettre de l'argent
et de donner ce que nous devions donner
il faut aussi aider à ce que des projets
durables dans le temps on va avoir un
accord de partenariat on va travailler
un échange de relations commerciales
c'est très important que ça se passe au
profit de la tunisie en préservant des
secteurs qui sont vitaux pour elle comme
certains secteurs des services ou de
l'agriculture
en tous les cas y est absolument évident
que notre parlement ici vous dis une
chose
l'europe doit répondre présente elle
doit être du côté de la tunisie et des
tunisiens
ceci n'est pas négociable pour nous
merci beaucoup